I'm gonna say this now so don't have you
boys coming need knocking in my tent all
night I know
I know they're come in the morning
and I know that bringing boys bigger in
ours and guns bigger than ours and a
mind to take the ones we got let me ask
you this do I look afraid i have written
with you boys through seven sovereign
nations on eight continents I have
fought with you boys through two wars
and eight deaths do I look afraid I have
seen you all at your best and I have
seen you all at your worst so believe me
when I tell you I am terrified I'm not
gonna sleep tonight but when we look up
on that hill tomorrow morning and we see
those boys we will turn that Shack to
the edge of the earth we will bar every
door flip every table when we run out of
bullets will take bottles to our
knuckles and claw their eyes out like a
goddamn Wolverines we are and if we're
surrounded beg for mercy but if they
surrender slaughter them
because none of you have my permission
to die